is eating in bed gross is it is eating  in bed gross no  sure i like it it keeps it like it keeps  your bed like kind of like ribbed you  know you got like little chips on you  no eat whatever you want you guys are  eating ass okay you guys are eating ass  i'm not an ass eater no no no it's fine  listen i have a hospital bed anyway my  boyfriend bangs me on the edge i sit on  the edge and then we bring the the  end up and then to his penis level i  present myself that's pretty cool yes  it's amazing everybody should try it the  four plays less we got to be like he's  going to be playing my nipples while i'm  going up you know but we do that so it's  like i can just  you eat in bed you get the crumbs you  just lift the bed up it falls over it's  gone get a dog by the way too the dog  will eat the food off your bed now your  ass i learned that mistake last time you  don't [ __ ] your dogs  that's bad